this tour is called yes it's it's your
first without Michael yes and I wonder
if we we've learned that he was in a bad
place
how how did you know repeat yourself can
you learn to he we learned that he was
in the bad place in the end of his life
a bad place I'm not nobody didn't he
didn't I mean it didn't have a good time
in his life that's not true he has a
great time see see that's what they want
you to think and they is the media the
propaganda the all the big media
tantrums to CNN's the Sky News the
euronews all of this what they want you
to think but the bottom line is Michael
was a gift and he's theirs
there will be no one like him
we miss him everyday when you asked
about we're on the stage his spirit is
there with us physically but spiritually
he's he's he's there you were all close
to him right yes was it was it still
could it be because he had so many
people around him could it be difficult
to get access to him as he was such a
big star and you know one of the things
I believe well let me back up first
about the family III think that and I
think my brothers would agree with me is
that first of all we're very thankful
that the Lord blessed his family with a
musical gift but I think the true
mission of the blessing that the Lord
gave this family is to spread unity
around the world through our music we
just love performing in love doing the
music but it took us to this level and
then it give us the opportunity to
travel the world well that's what I
loved about it was it like that until
the end is that what I say it's been
their way ever since day one and in you
know you have my father yes he did but
he had this ambition doing 50 shows in
London that was his plan what do you
even consider it was a hard service it
was a hundred shows yeah he had a heart
assault Lester list he didn't want to do
it or they dropped it down to 52
yeah 52 can you guys remember the last
time you were all together with Michael
yes yes oh yes
yes I may 14th two weeks before he
passed
yeah what did you do that there was a
function yeah for my mother and father
yeah that's right but in her yes you you
know how they came about right nope
haven't looked it Jenna and I were in
the South de France and we say we need
to do something for my mother and father
because they've been so great over the
years and we were there watching the
Formula One so we came back and Janet
put this dinner two together in
Latoya planned it all and we all showed
up and Michael came and Jackie's kids
with their mind what their and now I
told Michael I said I love that song you
did notion i love the backgrounds on it
and so we started singing together baby
don't make me baby don't make me baby
don't make me fly no wait gonna stay and
he told me well that means a lot to me
coming from you Jordan to me because I
like your your backgrounds are what you
do so we sat down in eighth he was
sitting next to Jackie he's making jokes
as usual I was across the room from
looking at him and we always have these
inside jokes oh we laugh and clown cuz
this is what we always did and after
that we said he said I'll see you at the
o2 theatres right and we say yeah we'll
see that we'll be there to see the other
half of those shows we were going to do
with him as the original Jackson 5 and
that was all planned and it was just a
shock to us that all this happened and
how I got the call you all may have been
some wheels Larry King called my wife
and said you know anything about your
mother
your mother Michael being rushed to the
hospital so I said nope and then 45
minutes ago by I know I called my mother
right then she said I'm on my way and
then 45 minutes had gone by and then
Janet had called me we said we hope this
is a rumor we hope it's not true and I
called my mother back she was at the
hospital and to hear her say he's dead
was the most horrifying thing and I fell
to my knees I was in Pasadena California
so my wife and I drove across town we
got closer to Westwood California and we
saw the helicopters in the sky and we
ran in and we saw we we ran down the
hall in the hospital but I consoled my
mother and the rest of the brothers
started coming coming in and then I want
to go see him
I wanted to see him and I walked in the
room and to see him lying there lifeless
he was still soft I kissed his forehead
and told
miss them so much and that's how we got
here I was Las Vegas with his kids
and we were just shopping around our
home there and dad with his two sons and
is this place of Michael shop all the
time to buy his antiques and they had a
monitor of him so we're just looking at
the monitor thoughtfully this guy came
past me and said Michael Jackson just
died I said Michael Jackson's dead what
is he talking about but I hear someone
else telling me is that walking Michael
Jackson's did you know and I called I
called my sister and she said yes he is
and so now we're gonna move to some more
uplifting uplifting yes and it still is
well see you don't get those when we
perform the musical stage because it's
healing for us and and that's why cuz
and you guys we got on the plane went to
Elaine's pack it was hard packing the
bags I couldn't stand yeah it makes a
week I couldn't stand at all it's just
it's tough yeah how do you feel about
his his doctor dr. Marie he was I'd be
like be honest with you I'd rather not
get in I don't want to talk about it yes
I feel the doctor they want the world to
think a black man killed the black man
but the doctor is just the finger to a
bigger hand it's much more involved and
and and when this news comes all over
here you all believe what you hear from
Sky News and you're old news and CNN and
Fox News and but it's not the truth it's
not the truth the doctor is a failure to
a bigger hand there's many more
involvement to this day we still don't
know who all came in that house because
the surveillance tapes were erased that
happened that night now how can the
authorities erase tapes so who are they
covering it up for who are they hiding
that's why there there's a room for that
death trial there's coming up in hey
because I want to know I don't want my
brother's death to be a mystery to us or
the public we want the world to know
what really happened to him
and now you are now you would perform
the songs you used to perform together
yes I'll do it feel better yeah all over
the world that you will do it also in in
Norway and Sweden yes and this is next
week yeah
yes the tour started in June under I
don't be smiling good and how is it to
get back you know in inform and to find
to find to find the moves again to be on
stage with these guys and it's
unbelievable I mean listen this will be
lovely we've been doing this since you
were 10 we were
we go bicycling you know the dancing
party moves you never forget
you don't forget it so and just the
energy and the energy from the audience
is just uplifts you when we get on stage
you see it it's a different person than
what we are offstage and on your say-so
Marlon no not this we tell me in front
of a audience and crime they're doing a
master there's an audience I'm about to
go and sit nobody's gonna go well you
are something
five sleep stages is a it's like when
you can make me sweat and let it out and
you know Wyclef was was hearing and we
adore so much and he would agree it's
it's like TV shows like this you you
really can't get loose the way you want
to but we're gonna try
no no but really is it's like the sweat
and then to in the loudness and miss a
night give us a taster well they're
gonna die short medley for you then
April regard and record a new record and
what might have might be working with us
on yeah somebody that works with you
guys told me that you a great singer
yeah well I know that you mention it
what I would like to listen to you guys
first to see if you're good enough for
me you know